how do all those universes that you're
talking you're talking about putting
them all together and collecting them
into a set how do they come into
existence why you need to justify it
otherwise it it's pointless to to uh
hypothecate their existence what are
your thoughts on many worlds generally
you know many worlds is basically a you
know if it if it can exist it does exist
but it's got things the matter of it
it's it's Everett's theory of course his
idea was well this the the uh uh ringer
equation is deterministic you know and
uh and uh everything that you know all
of those possibilities that exist in the
in in that equation should continue to
exist without Quantum collapse and so he
converted Quantum collapse events into a
Divergence of universes in order for
this to work you need certain you need
to have certain things certain
assumptions have to be in place for
example you need a fixed array in order
to parameterize all the events and
identify all your particles and events
in the universe so that you know just
exactly how the eventualities are
splitting uh it turns out that that
these assumptions are not autologic
viable so although Everett was correct
in that there is a metaverse he sort of
mischaracterized it it's not you know
Infinity upon Infinity of pointless
universes that are pointlessly diverging
in every tiny little Quantum event
that's ridiculous okay but the idea of a
of a metaverse of this this bur universe
that exists prior to in some sense the
reality that we inhabit that's a valid
idea so he sort of hit the nail on the
head and then he kind of went off on a
tang in order to make his theory work
you know in order to get his
interpretation of you know all of these
you know to interpret the the Multiverse
of the metaverse as being this
collection this vast collection of
pointlessly diverging universes
because we have telic recursion the way
that I understand that is that at each
cons spansion point in the manifold over
time somehow the points are evolving and
including their neighbors and I recall
you saying at the speed of light forget
about at the speed of light because that
can take us down another route
regardless there the speed of cons the
rate of cons spansion is usually what I
refer Okay cool so they're absorbing and
then that translates to a positive
cosmological constant because the
universe seems as if it's Contracting
from one point of view or expanding from
another
okay do you happen to have a prediction
for I know that your theory says there
should be a positive cosmological
constant does it have a calculation as
to what range it should look
like yes I've made calculations I'm not
going to announce them here I I'll
publish them first and then we can talk
about them okay let's get to some
philosophy what's meant by existence is
everywhere the choice to
exist well that's that active passive
Duality that we were talking about
before okay you you in in the ctmu tors
are basically secondary Quantum and
they've got to nucleate physical bodies
so they actually have to actively
participate in their own birth do they
do so of some Proto will or is it happen
stance that they inherit the will of the
universe the will of the universe is to
exist
therefore these therefore at you know in
any part of the universe in the
non-terminal domain you've got things
everywhere that are seeking to exist you
know the the terminal domain provides
them with resources that they can use to
actualize themselves and this is what
happens and you mean that they want to
exist at the dionic level at this
terminal level or you mean to say that
they want to exist at all because to me
as I hear that when someone says this
entity wants to to exist it implies it
already exists you need a physical in
order to truly exist in the sense that
most people mean you actually need this
this form content feedback okay so in
order to fully exist things do require
some kind of a terminal body where
people get confused is they think that
their terminal body can only be of a
certain kind in a certain world all
right that's not necessarily true there
can be many different kinds of terminal
realization for example there can be an
afterlife uh heaven or a hell for
example in which you can exist and have
another kind of terminal body which was
generated just for that world or just
for that heaven or hell you see it
doesn't necessarily have to be right
here one way or another you need those
resources in order to fully instantiate
Your Existence otherwise your existence
never achieves full resolution it is
never fully actualized the universe
wants to actualize itself everywhere it
can that's why we have this profusion of
life right that's why we have all these
different species all these different
organisms Telesis wants to actualize
itself it wants to exist and this world
provides it with the resources to do
so so is it akin to God wanting to exist
God wanting there to be more God yes
that's exactly right that's that's why
that's why I say you know reality is
closed it has to be totally
self-justified right exist
is the will to exist and you've also
heard me possibly use a term called
triality right as the identity of
reality This Global operator descriptor
is not
only an object and a relationship it's
also a process or an operator right in
other words you can imagine that the
universe is not just an object it's an
event it's a creation event that's what
the universe is a self-creation event or
self-identification event
you see and that everywhere in the
universe these self-creation or
self-identification events are seeking
to occur they're trying to occur
particles are you know are being created
and annihilated everywhere in the
universe all right because they're
inheriting this will to exist from the
universe itself and this is a Criterion
of existence without it existence is
impossible right you can't just exist
for a second and there not be an
operation that that that maintains your
existence that because that second is
meaningless okay there's it's got to be
a permanent existence it's got to be in
some sense atemporal or Eternal that's
what God is in C basically God is being
equated to Ultimate Reality so God is
eternal in this sense and to get Vicken
steinan when you say Eternal do you
mean infinite temporal length or
timelessness basically we're not talking
about we're talking about atemporality
which is timelessness is important okay
in other words it's prior to time it's
pretemporal in the way okay it just
exists as a
canus exists as as an Impulse as an
imperative but it is not fully
actualized without existence and all it
goes into and there these existential
criteria are what most physicists and
other people leave out of their
understanding of reality but these
criteria are logically necessary and
they do in fact say
before we get further some people may be
turned off by the use of the word God so
I'd like you to Define how you use it
because you have a well it comports with
the general definition of God but it's
more specific well I've done everybody
the favor of of making an acronym on it
Global operator description the identity
of reality or Ultimate Reality okay as
far as personifying it is concern
anthropomorphizing it or whatever you
want to call it um that follows from the
properties of the
god of the global operator scripture and
we find out that it has certain
properties ordinarily attributed to God
by people who have religious
beliefs usually monotheistic beliefs
that's the correct way to so that's what
that's what I mean when I say God I'm
not saying well I'm not you know
necessarily the Christian God the Muslim
God the Jewish god whatever kind of God
right I mean the global operator
descriptor and it does have sentience it
it is all of the criteria that go into
the basic religious definition of God
creating the universe all the rest of
that stuff these are actually can
actually be validly interpreted in the
ctmu the ctmu models those properties
therefore God
exists now these tertiary tellers come
into existence because of their will to
exist at least from my understanding but
at the same time at the secondary the
universe's will to exist
at our level it seems like not everyone
has a will to exist which you also
mentioned is equivalent to evil or at
least cognate with it is it possible for
a particle to have an anti- will to
exist most people who commit commit
suicide basically have no will to exist
they're not antiexistence okay so
suicide is not necessarily evil in the
sense of uh of a mass murderer he tries
to destroy civilization in human species
they're not quite the same
thing can a particle commit suicide in a
sense can a particle have a suicide
particle does not have sufficient
self-modeling capacity to make that
decision for itself that's why we
require secondary tellor they have the
self-modeling the advanced self-modeling
capacity to be able to make decisions of
that complexity and only they can do
them it's why they're necessary that's
why we have to be Quant coherent Quant
in this universe can you talk about what
good is defined as and what evil is
defined
as well basically good is what reality
as a whole wants teleology the will of
God people have many terms for it okay
and evil is its opposite the negation of
it simple as that and good
wants good wants self-actualization and
self-identification that is what the
universe is doing it is one huge massive
self-identification event everything in
it
all of the events are
self-identification events that go into
its
self-actualization what's meant by
self-actualization that's a term that
some new people use let's delineate it
well okay well as physicist would call
it a Quantum wave function
collapse okay the quantum wave function
you know something is the quing to the
the squ your equation you've got a
Quantum wave function it's expands you
know it's radiating out into space and
then suddenly poof it collapses that's
inner expansion and collapse okay that's
a cons spansive meta event right this is
what the universe is made out of in the
ctmu you're no longer just looking at
particles you're looking at more
advanced kinds of water that are much
much easier to tie together in the
consense of MTH I tend to get bogged
down and worri so I'm going to press you
sometimes and it may seem unduly
persnikity but when you say selfa
isn't it is it not the case that there
only self-actualization not just
actualization because the
universe is itself that's correct that
is correct everything is self
actualization of the universe if not
necessarily of you if you enjoyed that
clip then the full podcast is out right
now you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI